here's video of of a woman that I prayed
to God by the end of tomorrow night we
can call former New York Governor Kathy
hochel just getting crushed on what's
going on in New York with the crime okay
but I'm going to interrupt you then
here's the problem we don't feel safe
you might be working closely with mayor
Adams you may have spent a whole lot of
money but I walk into my Pharmacy and
everything is on lockdown because of
shoplifters I'm not going in the subway
people don't feel safe in this town so
you may have done these things but right
now we're not feeling good we're worried
we could be San Francisco we'll never be
San Francisco why because we are already
making a difference we already have
homicides and shootings down
dramatically
dramatically from what they had been
last year
lady you were in charge last year too
and if you want to parse it your guy
Andrew Cuomo was in charge a little bit
before that nobody buys any of this
anymore and the fact that MSNBC again
they're doing it two days before their
the election because they're covering
their butts they ushered in all of this
the mainstream media covered for the
Democrats they applauded as Democrat
antifa and BLM people burned down cities
and destroyed Pep Boys and Target and
all that you got it and now in the last
moments as they realize what's about to
happen now they have to cover their own
butts so they don't look like complete
sellouts